You can get it online.
You can get it at the TikTok Shop links right here.
My kids said that I look like one of those, um.
I look like I come from one of those rich mountain towns.
I mean, I am in Colorado,
but I fucking love it. It's super cute.
So you wear something cute underneath,
and then, oh,
but it may be a little cold,
throw on your little jacket.
It's perfect. It is perfect. Perfect.
It's got two pockets right here.
Got another pocket right here.
And it truly is the perfect.
It's light enough for fall.
You're not gonna get super hot.
It's not big and bulky. I absolutely love it.
And it is linked right here.
You don't need to find it in a little mountain town.
It's on TikTok Shop.